There is no safar. There are no owls.
There is no contagion.
This means that
these things are not to be taken in the
way that they were commonly understood
and believed in the time of Jah
in the time prior to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam's
prior to his messengership
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam in a very dark time in human
history.
A time when
the majority of humanity had fallen
into the clutches of a shaitan
and he came to release them from those
clutches and to release them from
the
from the path of damnation that the
majority of humanity was upon.
And so there were certain beliefs at
that time. There were certain things
that were commonly
known as kind of truisms or cultural
idioms etc. And the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam and this narration
and in others it is invalidating
that perception
not invalidating
necessarily
the actual physical thing that that
perception or that superstition is
attached to. So he says
there is no
ad meaning contagion
and it doesn't mean that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam doesn't affirm
that infectious diseases can't be
transmitted
and cannot be contagious. This is
something that every person who observes
an illness
and observes it in any group of people
will come to the conclusion that yes
this is something that is contagious. If
a person is ill with this particular
illness and they interact physically
with someone else who is healthy that
they may that they may infect them that
this illness may be contagious. However,
the beliefs of the Mushri, the beliefs
of the Jahidi Arabs at the time were a
step beyond this amount or this
portion of reason. It was a step beyond
that. They believed in contagion so
strongly, so earnestly
that they did not believe that
it was something to the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that it was something that once it had
begun to spread
that
it will
cause infection
no matter what and that it is not
something that is by the decree of Allah
that it is by the will and permission of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and this is where the difference between
the Muslim and the non really shows
itself
with respect to something a
contagious illness.
A believer understands
that even
if he is exposed to an illness, he can
still not be harmed except by the will
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And that if a person
has been willed by Allah to become ill
that he doesn't need a contagion for
that to happen
that it will happen by the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala no matter how far
away he may be from that particular
illness.
A man asked the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam about this very thing.
He said,
and this is an extension of a narration
similar to this where the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
that a contagion in that sense and in
that way is a myth.
Superstition
largely superstitious.
And so
one of the companions
said,
"Oh messenger of Allah, we observe that
if a man has a
sick camel, a camel, that is a is a type
of illness. it's kind of ringorm
for
for camels. then
that if it is put into a pen with other
healthy camels that they get sick. We
observe this. We see this. The prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said,
"If that is the case and it is as
believed at that time, then if it is not
by the will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala,
then how did the first
camel get sick?" What we would refer to
as patient zero. How did that happen?
And so illness
even though it has biological
and physical contraptions that we can
look at as cause and effect and can
become contagious etc. This does not
exempt it from the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. It is still by the
will of Allah.
And a person will only be afflicted with
that which Allah has written upon him.
And a person
who has not been
willed by Allah to become ill will not
become ill. Now this doesn't mean that
a person is
you know irresponsible. No, the
companions
observed great
caution with respect to
very contagious diseases because they
knew that the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam told them that if you
hear of a plague or a contagion in a
land do not go to it and do not leave it
if you are there at that land so as not
to spread it.
However, still a person believes in the
decree of Allah. This does not inter
interfere
with the decree of Allah because also
one of the beliefs even amongst some of
the Muslim is that a person may be
killed or may become ill or die in
adolescence and that all children or all
youth who die in adolescence or die in
their youth that this somehow now was
before Allah had willed for them to die.
And so they still have time
that they that Allah had written for
them. And so they will do things like
haunt the places where they were. Right?
If a if a child dies in a in a
particular home that now that child's
soul will continue to haunt the hallways
of that home right until its time is up
that Allah had originally written of old
age whatever 50 60 years and then it
will die then the soul is taken as if we
were created and our souls were created
to hang out in
you know people's basement and haunt
them haunt the new homeowners until our
time is up. Or if a person is murdered
before their time or if a person is
killed in some kind of horrific accident
that this person's spirit will continue
to haunt. And these are things that
even I remember growing up that the
elders back in
back in in Palestine and Jordan,
these places used to say and used to
teach us. And these are nothing more
than superstitions. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala takes this all back to the
general statement of
he says
and there are no valid
omens. There are no valid
true
omens.
First of all, the idea of an omen is an
indicator of something that is to occur
in the future. Right? that if I'm
leaving to go on a journey and
a bird flies off and it takes a
right, it banks right, okay, continue
with my journey is going to be a good
journey. And if it banks left, I better
turn around and plan this for a
different day because something very
terrible is going to happen. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has said
none knows what
is in the future except for Allah. None
in the heavens or the earth. And Allah
has repeated throughout the Quran and
indicated in no uncertain terms
and said explicitly
that only Allah knows what the future
holds.
Only Allah knows what the future holds
and those whom Allah informs, those whom
Allah makes privy to that knowledge.
Therefore, these so-called omens
of the behaviors of certain animals and
that these animals are going to reflect
something ominous to come or something
good to come. This is pure fable. This
is pure superstition.
This is pure nonsense that a shaitan
whispers into the hearts of men and into
the minds of men in order to weaken
their resolve and obstruct their
relationship and path to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. We will stop there for
today. Inshallah we will continue this
after
Ramadan.
during Ramadan and in the next week,
inshallah, we will be dealing with some
of the rulings of fasting and some of
the of fasting, commonly asked
questions, etc.
Subhanahuaala.
And
[Silence]
Allahbar
Allah.
I should
[Silence]
I don't know
I
[Silence]
don't Hallelujah.
Honor.
[Silence]
Allah.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Are you
forch.
[Silence]
foram.
forch.
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala has mentioned
in Bakar
with respect to
one of the
greatest and most pertinent
and one of the most
dire pillars
of the five pillars of Islam.
the pillar of fasting
of fasting the month of Ramadan.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to oh you who have believed
indeed fasting has been prescribed
upon you all as it has upon those
nations which have preceded you in order
that you may
obtain tawa
in order that you may
through this act of worship
rise to the level of the mut
and that through this act of worship
you may use it as a means to shield and
protect yourselves from the punishment
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in this
life and in the hereafter which is the
essence of tawa
He tells us subhanahua
fasting has been prescribed upon you all
as it has upon those previous those
prior nations before you.
What do we understand from this? We
understand
that fasting
and fasting this act of worship is so
beloved to Allah
is so integral
to our journey to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
that
he has made it something that is a part
of every single nations s
worship of Allah that he has made it an
obligatory
factor, an obligatory element in their
journey to Allah
that every nation that has preceded us,
every pro, every messenger
who has come to his people,
he has taught them some iteration
of the five pillars of Islam and fasting
is no different.
It is a part and an integral part of
every Muslim's journey to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. It may not have
been
in the exact same way with the exact
same rules and parameters
that fasting is as we know it today as
the of Muhammad Sam. Wasam,
but no doubt similar.
And the concept of fasting, refraining
from certain things, food and drink,
namely sexual pleasure during the
daylight hours,
to sacrifice this for the pleasure of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is
something that Allah loves dearly from
his servant
and he subhanahu wa ta'ala has obligated
it upon every nation that has preceded
us and he subhanahua has made it a
prerequisite to tawa
said
in order that you may obtain tawa
in order that you may shield yourselves
successfully from the punishment of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then and of
course fasting can mean a lot of things
and fasting
at its face seems very impending
something that is very difficult for
people to do
and so this verse may elicit some
feelings of apprehension
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
following verse
to quell any concerns
that this fasting may be something that
is too difficult for us to do that it is
something too imposing. He says a
number of days that are numbered.
It's not most of the year, not most of
the time, not even the majority of the
time or even half
or a substantial portion, merely a few
days in the grand scheme of things.
Contrasted with the rest of the year, it
is a very small portion, but it is a
very substantial portion. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has obligated
fasting upon us and he has identified
the month. He says, "Subhan
Ramadan,
this is the month of Ramadan in which
the Quran was first revealed,
in which the Quran was first sent down
upon our messenger Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam."
And so
this month of Ramadan was something that
is a known month from the lunar
calendar
that the Arabs of Jahedia
considered
the ninth month of the lunar calendar in
that time
and was hence affirmed
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and his
messenger as the ninth month of the
Islamic lunar calendar and it was
referred to as the month of Ramadan
from Ramblah
which is the desert sand when it bakes
and becomes very hot.
It's referred to as Ramadan
in order to that the Arabs viewed it as
a time of year that is usually a very
hot very difficult time of year with
respect to heat. And the thing that is
most prominent, the most unanimous and
ubiquitous of feelings and emotions
during the month of Ramadan is one of
thirst, one of heat. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala named this month in
the Quran. It's the only month that is
named that is mentioned by name in the
Quran which is interesting
because not even the four sacred months
are mentioned by name. They are alluded
to. They are referred to as the sacred
months.
However, Ramadan is not one of those
four sacred months. And so Allah
mentioned it by name in the Quran in
order to raise its level and make
Ramadan as a prelude
in order for us to prepare ourselves for
the coming sacred months.
And so the month of Ramadan
is a month that was known to the Jahia
Arabs in pre-Islamic times. It's not
something new to them. And also the
concept of fasting was not new to them
either.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chose
this month
112th
of a person's entire year
It is not too little to where it has no
effect on a person's year. Nor is it too
much to where it impedes a person's
livelihood.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has made it
consequential
but not imposing.
Allah tells us that he desires ease for
us and does not desire difficulty for
us. However,
more important than our ease is our
relationship with Allah and that it is
built upon a level of sacrifice and that
is what Ramadan really is about.
However, Ramadan
as we have heard is a beloved month to
Allah. It is a month of great baraka,
great blessings from Allah. It is a
month that is given sacredness in its
own right.
It is a month that is to act as a
prelude
to the three consecutive sacred months
that follow.
And the month of Ramadan
is a month in which we practice this act
of worship, this fasting.
Very important.
Why is it so critical?
Because the act of fasting
is a worship that brings a person
very near to Allah and acts as a
stepping stone
for a person to be elevated in his or
her righteousness.
Our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
has said in the narration of Abi
collected by both Bkari and Muslim.
He said,
he said that Allah himself has said all
of the deeds of the human being are
potentially for him except for fasting.
It is only for me and I personally
reward the servant for a successful
fast. What does that mean?
All of the deeds are for him except for
fasting. Now the scholars of Islam have
mentioned a couple of interpretations to
this narration. All of them are correct.
And one of those is that in any act of
worship that a person does, the
remaining four or remaining
pillars of Islam, a person could
potentially
use these acts of worship to gain some
kind of worldly notoriety.
person may pray and show off in his
prayer. A person may give generously in
zak and
in order to be praised as generous. A
person may travel for Hajj and Omrah in
order to be praised as a Hajj and
someone who has made this very difficult
and sacrificial pilgrimage except for
fasting.
Fasting is a secret between you and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. No one knows
if you are truly fasting except for you
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Imagine
person could eat a five course meal and
then come out and be just as hungry as
everyone else and be just as fasting as
everyone else is.
However, if a person observes his fast
and refrains from those things which
break a person's fast in private as he
does in public, this is an indication
that he truly believes in Allah. The
only reason is because he understands
that this is for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so if a person truly is fasting
privately as he is publicly,
this is something which is very private
between himself and Allah. And so Allah
will maintain that privacy
on the day of judgment and personally
reward a person for his fasting.
Except for fasting, it is for me and I
personally will reward
the servant for fasting. He will not
commission an angel to reward the person
for fasting. He himself will reward a
person for fasting
in order to maintain
this secrecy and this privacy and this
intimacy that the person had established
in his life in the dunya.
It is very similar to
the prophet Sam
said
he said only a believer
will maintain his woo.
What does that mean? Meaning that who
knows if you have wudoo or not? Who
knows if your woo is valid or not? Who
knows if you have broken your woo or
not? There's no apparent physical
difference between a person who is in a
state of wuboo and a person who is not.
And so
if a person
prays, hypocrites may pray.
But only a believer will make wudoo.
Only a believer will maintain his wudoo.
A hypocrite will not. Someone who does
not believe in Allah's observation will
not. Only a believer. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam made one of the
strongest indicators of a person's e
is his maintaining of wudoo.
Likewise is the act of fasting Ramadan
and fasting in general.
This act of worship though it goes a lot
further than just refraining from eating
and drinking. I mean, when you think
about it, not eating anything, not
drinking anything during the daylight
hours,
it's something that
maybe could be difficult.
It's something that could be
challenging,
but not really. It's not really that
challenging.
As a matter of fact, most people can do
it. Soccer moms do it so that they can
trim down for the summer. It's not
something particularly impressive that a
person refrain from eating and drinking.
What's impressive
is that a person refrain from the
prohibitions of Allah. That's really
where the rubber meets the road. That's
really the essence of fasting.
Our prophet Sam
has said
he said true fasting is not that a
person refrain from eating and drinking.
True fasting is that a person refrain
from that which is prohibited and
refrain from that which wastes a
person's time, that which is
inconsequential,
that which is unnecessary.
That is true fasting.
Imagine that. Imagine with me that
during every moment of your daytime
hours
during the month of Ramadan,
you didn't change anything about your
life.
The only thing you did was refrain
during those hours from anything haram
and anything that will not gain benefit
in this life or the hereafter. And you
do that for 30 days consecutively.
Imagine how lifech changing,
imagine how transformative
that period will be if we JUST DO THAT.
NOTHING ELSE. I know we all have
Ramadan resolutions. Every Muslim does
to the point that as SHAN USES IT
AGAINST US, ANYTIME we consider doing
something good, Shan comes and says,
"Hey, just wait till Ramadan. do it
then. Don't start now. Wait till Ramadan
comes. Then you'll really do it. Enjoy
it now. And then when Ramadan comes,
you're going to be best. You're going to
be awesome. Just New Year's
resolutions.
I'm going to start on the 1st of
January. What's the difference between
the 1st of January and the 15th of
September? from the 10th of July, from
the 4th of June, nothing at all. Zero.
There is no difference. It is merely
something in our minds. And so people
to have a resolution
this Ramadan.
I am going to just I'm going to be
amazing.
Everything's going to change suddenly
for me in Ramadan.
I'm going to
immediately as soon as the sun sets
on
the 29th or the 30th day of
Shabban
immediately I'm going to wake up out of
bed the next day a completely changed
person. This is not how change happens.
No change worth having happens this way.
Change is something that happens
incrementally.
Change is something that happens with
discipline and over the passage of time.
Doesn't happen overnight. Person doesn't
suddenly wake up a different person.
This is something that has to be
practiced and worked towards. And a
person has to trip and fall and stumble
on the path of change before they are
able to truly embrace it.
And so the month of Ramadan
is not
for us to have all of these incredible
lofty ideas that we're going to do and
we want to wear 10 hats at the same time
and we want to do everything everything
perfect. And then the first day comes
and the second day comes and our systems
are shocked from the change and we want
to try to maintain that and we're unable
and then we stumble and we start to walk
a little slower and we start to sweat a
little bit and then the same was
comes back and says hey you already
ruined it man you already ruined this
[Arabic recitation]
And so we all just kind of regress back
into what we were doing before. And then
what happens? You wake up one day and
you look in the mirror and 20 Ramadans
have passed. Nothing has changed. 30
gray hair has filled your beard or your
head. Nothing has changed. Nothing has
changed. The same resolutions that you
made 20 or 30 years ago. Why is that?
Because the game that a shaitan plays is
promise him today and he'll promise you
tomorrow. That's the agreement. Give me
today and I'll give you tomorrow.
Tomorrow is neither yours or his. But
somehow he promises it to you. And the
only thing you really have is today and
you give it away.
And every day we do the same thing.
That's not what the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam teaches us
with respect to Ramadan. He doesn't
teach us to come up with these amazing
transformative wear 10 hats things
overnight. No, he says
he says true fasting is not
that a person merely refrain from eating
and drinking. True fasting is that a
person refrain from that which is haram
and that which is unnecessary, that
which is inconsequential, that which is
immaterial, that which is not
beneficial.
Killing time as we call it, something
that will not benefit us in this life or
the next. This is called
and is anything of speech or action. If
you just focus on that,
if you just focus on that,
by the end of Ramadan, you will be a new
person looking back at yourself in the
mirror.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
And then
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam said,
"Whoever does not leave off
impermissible and inconsequential
statements and actions,
then Allah has no use for this person to
leave off his food and drink. That's the
true essence of fasting.
Islamus.
[Silence]
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Oh,
the Lord. Stand shouldertosh shoulder.
Close all of the gaps.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Fore
[Silence]
for
me.
Allah
Allahbel
Allahel.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
amen.
Feed.
All
Allahel.
[Silence]
All
amum.
Brothers and sisters, I have few very
important announcements and please bear
with me. first, as you announced last
week, Imam Ali will be administering the
Sunday program, Sunday school program
and the youth programs inshallah. So in
that vein there will be a this evening
there is going to be a a lecture after
Isha. This will be interactive and it is
are you ready for the Ramadan?